I love this time of year I love seeing
the little kids all smiling and I am a
little bit in shock how many people now
think it is cool to be gloomy Wall
Street Journal actually agrees with me
they printed an article out that hit
just recently it says why is it so cool
to be gloomy like pessimism is in
instead of optimism oh all stuck words
all the glasses have empty article says
this has the percentage of the world's
population that lives in extreme poverty
almost doubled almost halved or stayed
the same in the past 20 years what do
you think by the way has it doubled has
it gone in half or is it stayed the same
in the last 20 years some percentage of
the population of the world that is in
extreme poverty when the swedish
statistician and public health expert
Hans Rosling began asking people the
question in 2013 he was astounded by the
responses only 5% of Americans got the
right answer extreme poverty has been
cut almost in half
a chimpanzee would do better he pointed
out mischievously by picking an answer
at random so people are worse than
ignorant they believe they know many
dire things about the world that are in
fact untrue statistically untrue
in fact untrue not your feeling an
actual fact Rosling published a
magnificent book arguing against such
reflexive pessimism the title says it
all fact fulness 10 reasons were wrong
about the world and while things are
better than you think as the author of a
book called rational optimist mention
the same kind of thing okay people cling
to pessimism about the state of the
world John Stuart Mill neatly summarized
10 that this tendency as far back as
1828 he said quote I have observed that
not not that not the man who hopes when
others despair but the man who despairs
when others hope is admired by a large
class of persons as a sage it's cool to
be gloomy is going to collapse Trump is
gonna kill everyone we're all going to
die it's cool to be gloomy it's
interesting any Christmas you're gloomy
oh my gosh
the persistence of pessimism about
planet the planet requires some
explanation beyond the facts themselves
therefore bad news is usually more
sudden than good news which is usually
gradual therefore bad news is more news
worthy battles bombings accidents
murders storms scandals and disasters of
all kinds tend to dominate the news if
it bleeds it leads
as they say in the newspaper business
back when we had newspapers
by contrast the gradual reduction in
poverty in the world rarely makes a
sudden splash the increase of the stock
market is gradual it rarely makes a
splash you never see the stock market
stock market spike - today as a leading
headline you always saw that's all you
see stock market spiked never you always
see the stock market crashed it crashed
you remember back when it crashed that's
how we talk the human tendency towards
pessimism is absolutely amazing did you
know that people don't make as much
money as they used to the young the
Millennials they cannot make it they're
overwhelmed with student loan debt they
have no opportunity at America today and
wages are falling have you heard this
it's all over the news well poverty is
going to overtake us the number of
people in poverty is really sad but
it's half what it used to be by the way
okay here's the actual facts on wages
this from Pew Research after bottoming
out in 2011 incomes are rising for
American households this was 2011 those
headed by a millennial someone aged 22
to 37 now earn more than young adult
households did at nearly any time in the
past 50 years according to census data
actual statistics not your feelings hmm
the gross of the growth in household
income among young adults has been
driven in part by millennial women who
are working more and being paid more
than young and young women were in
previous years because we all know that
women are underpaid and the wages for
women are slave wages we send the women
off to the Salt Mines we pay them a
dollar a year
no the statistical facts are that women
are paid more than they've ever been
paid in history which is good they
should be they should be paid the same
shouldn't be underpaid just because of
your sex or your color anything else
that's not true I mean even if you don't
have hair you should be paid the same
for doing the same job right I mean
seriously I don't like bald ism any more
than I like racism or sexism autism is
the one I'm most worried about by the
way because I'm privileged there's a lot
of whining going on out there
gloomy is cool but the problem is it's
not accurate incomes of households
headed by fifty four to seventy two year
olds which would be the baby boomers
today are at record levels while those
of current Gen X households about the
same as the peak earnings of similarly
aged households in the past not a single
category of age are wages down since
2011 they're up dramatically their level
or they're up according to actual census
data now I don't know about your
particular personal situation but I will
not give you permission to
Wein we can help you with your situation
that's what we do here we're glad to
help you and we want to do that and I
don't want anyone to live in extreme
poverty and I don't want anyone to have
a bad life but you cannot say that
there's a systemic problem with the
economy and this capitalism idea is now
a failure
now poverty extreme poverty worldwide is
half of what it's ever been and wages
are up for Millennials more than any
time in history since 2011 in the last
50 years the highest wages of that age
group interesting another article from
The Economist two people who believe the
world used to be a better place and
especially to those who argue globalism
has done more economic harm than good
there's a simple powerful answer in 1981
42 percent of the world's population
were extremely poor according to the
World Bank they were not just poorer
than a large majority of their
compatriots which many rich countries
define poverty among their own citizens
today but they're absolutely destitute
since then the number of people in
absolute poverty has fallen by about 1
billion and the number of non poor
people has gone up by roughly 4 billion
in 2013 the most recent year for stats
10.7% not 42% of the world are living in
extreme poverty
Merry Christmas